Vegas was supposed to be your last time
on stage in Las Vegas during the
residency I thought that that was going
to be my last time doing concerts and
you decided to do the finals oh no when
you announce this tour you also
announced that it would be your last now
you got a new record yeah
will you two were there yes I will you
will I really thought that would be the
only time that would be able to do that
you were good but I succeeded I was I
was it was so much work yeah it takes me
an hour and a half just to warm up for a
show so it's exhausting but I had more
stamina than I thought yeah so now that
I've gotten in music I'm really
motivated to do that new music life it's
been 15 years since Shania released a
full-length record but this September
the queen of country will return with
her highly anticipated fifth studio
album now the record includes life's
about to get good
with Shania debuted on The Today Show
with their point where prince reached
out to you yes he was the first person
to reach out bruiser
yes I was still only separated at that
point I was nowhere near getting my
voice together yet I had no confidence
in the voice yet and I have no songs
that were written and ready so he was
way ahead of me
Shania has five Grammys sold over 75
million albums worldwide and has
countless hits like up you're still the
one
[Music]
and man I feel like a woman man I feel
at woman but the new record marks the
first time she and I worked on a
full-length project without her former
collaborator and ex-husband Mutt Lange
and Shania tells us that's not the only
first she wants to cross off her bucket
list like I want to act now I never did
one oh yeah have you let it be known
that you want to act I've have so has
anybody now anything yet a script for
anything a treatment no I'm saying it
now for the first time you're saying it
out for the first time
okay I think we could probably I'm not
putting out there to advertise myself
but I just I'm just telling you my dream